hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today is my buddy daryn olien
returning for i think his third
appearance on the podcast
darren is the indiana jones of
superfoods
he's the new york times best-selling
author of an amazing book called
superlife
and he is also the co-star along with
zac efron of the number one hit netflix
series
down to earth he's here today it's an
amazing conversation
if you enjoy the content that we work
hard to put out every single week
hit that subscribe button and also hit
that little notification bell
so you can be alerted every time there's
a new video appreciate you taking this
journey with me
and without further ado this is me and
darren olean
[Music]
so a lot's happened since the last time
that we did this
dude your life has exploded
it's incredible yeah amongst the other
craziness it's it's it is incredible
yeah
uh first of all congrats it's all very
well earned i'm super proud of you
and it's been such a delight to see
america or the world kind of embrace
what i've already known for so long and
things that you've been talking about
and living like your entire life
it's gone massively broad
i would imagine there's a little bit of
vertigo with all of that i mean the
number one show on netflix is crazy
yeah it's it's hard to have a
relationship with that
i think that um it's almost
if i can describe the experience it's
almost like oh cool
that's cool like and yet you're seeing
the numbers rise you're seeing
the followers rise and and you're like
and then the book new york times was
seller and the podcast and then
and then the show and and i think that
it doesn't it feels like a
responsibility
in a good way rather than
look at me like it it really feels
well now you have the platform to speak
more broadly and potently about the
things that you care about and have
always cared about and just to recap for
people
that are perhaps new to you last time we
talked
it was on the eve of baruch's launching
to the world
and since that moment which was i don't
even know when it was a couple years ago
i think at this point maybe a year and a
half ago
you have co-hosted this show down to
earth with zac
efron it went to number one on netflix
your book super life
just hit the new york times bestseller
list you launched a podcast
it went to number one in the health and
fitness
category on itunes and your instagram i
think maybe what did you have like
70 000 or something like that before all
of this like
mid-30s oh mid-30s and now you're at
like 400
that is the power of netflix it's
unbelievable
yeah you know the funny thing is our
friend neil strauss said
there was another uh
show that came out similarly and
a different show completely but they
were doing really well but the guy
didn't
receive a lot of followers and the only
thing that i can
attest to this is and we can unpack
a lot of this stuff as to the
culmination of the show
and how my idea of the intensity of the
information
made its way through the production
and through the understanding of the
audience
that i don't have
but what i see is that through the
levity
through the lightness of how we
delivered the show
with some information clearly it's
somehow
reached across the aisle
of other people that don't necessarily
live this way don't necessarily have
the same amount of awareness about
how they are sitting in the world as it
relates to their own health
and the health of the planet so
so it's it's such a beautiful thing
to see regular people that were
that i am that you are they're we're no
different
but that they are
tagline message thousands of them
this way saying my life is different
i am never the same i'm gonna
do something better with my life over
and over and over and over again from
a nine year old to a 70 year old yeah
that rich is worth everything
yeah it's a beautiful exercise in
humility
as well right like we talk every week so
i've been with you from the outset
of this whole experience and i know very
well that
had you had your druthers this would
have been a much more serious
intense deep dive and issue based and
policy-based
you had sort of grumbled along the way
like i don't know if this is going to
work like
i want it to be like this it looks like
it's going in this direction
and yet to see it so well received on
the broadest level
is a lesson right in that a like i don't
know everything
b these producers understood something
that i didn't because if i'd had my way
maybe it wouldn't have connected in this
way right 100
yeah like you spot on with the struggle
because i did you know i you know the
beautiful thing is we can get into the
origin story of how this even came about
oh i love the origin story tell the
origin story
well people people
talking to you like like
this come on this is the origin story
right here right now you know the the
the podcast that we did i don't think it
was the first one probably the second
was the second one probably yeah
um it came by way of the show
so we did that show something about
how i what i said who i was
i don't know but
zack heard it and he was like
what is this guy doing i want to know
about this person
what is what is he up to and so he
reached out
to your buddy who's now my buddy as well
connor dwyer
the olympian badass swimmer that
you guys are mutual friends with so zach
is friends with connor you're friends
with connor so
zach reached out to connor to get my
number to see if it was okay
that you give zach my number right
because zach was interested who i still
haven't met by the way
that's that's funny um and and kind of
how it crystallized well one of the
aspects of it and i told this on the
podcast recently so forgive me if you've
already heard it but
i went out riding with connor and zach's
brother
dylan along with simon garen's who's
like this
incredible tour de france rider who was
visiting from overseas at the time
and after our ride i'm like come on
let's go over to darren's house and i
i took those guys over to your house
pre-burning down and we're gonna get
into all of that
um and you showed them your whole setup
and they were like zach would just kill
to be here
and all that so i think that trickled
back to him as well yeah
and set in motion what would become this
incredible tv show that you guys have
done together
yeah so so when zach finally it was
months later
i've forgotten right so you said yeah
yeah it didn't happen quickly
no so apparently zac efron wants to
reach out to you
is it okay that i give connor
the number to give to zach and i was
like sure
you know whatever that's fine and so
i forgot about it and then i remember
the moment
where i got this cold when i mean cold
like i didn't
know the number uh text and it was like
hey darren this is zac efron
i really enjoyed i heard the podcast i
really connect with what you're doing
like a very
sweet and i ran up by my you know eliza
my
then wife and she was like wow that
sounds really genuine
cool so i was like dude let's have lunch
then
and so we ate at this great um vegan
restaurant golden mean
and we sat upstairs away from everybody
and sat there for a
minimum of two hours and he was largely
just asking about
what i was up to right and then it was
kind of at the very
end where we walked out he's
so what else are you doing i said well
you know for 10 years people have been
asking me to do this superfood hunting
show but i really wanted to broaden it
because superfood hunting has
woken me up to environmental issues
because i've seen a lot and i've
connected to a lot of people
so i want to do the show longevity
principles
health food systems agriculture
water like i want to get and he was like
wait a minute so you travel
you'd go to all these pla i'm like yeah
of course
so he got so fired up and then we kind
of said bye with staying
stay in touch then he called me two
hours later
he basically said you know i have this
existing deal with netflix
in a topic that i just am not that
excited about
it was travel it was with other
celebrities eating in countries of
origin
that these celebrities connected to like
feeding phil or that phil rosenthal show
yeah so it was like going to those
countries
eating that authentic food and a couple
celebrities hanging out
and they shot the pilot no one was
really
from what i hear no one was really that
jazzed about it nor was zach
so he asked his team and his pre in the
production
could we kind of bring these concepts
together
and basically do what darren was
suggesting
and i'll be damned like he walked that
in
uh everyone kind of i'm putting words on
it reluctantly
but right but i think they trusted
something
and and then over time i got into
pre-production and we spent a lot of
time
ironing out you know the show and the
the production team was
jazzed because they're like oh wow
meaningful
powerful content well typically in a
situation like this
the producers would be shouldering the
burden of trying to find the locations
and who are the people we're gonna meet
with
and what are the themes we're gonna
explore but you brought this
lifetime of experience in relationships
to this i suspect
and i want to hear more about this that
most of the places you went to you've
been to before
these are people you already know who
are in your life as a result of you
being this superfood hunter for all
these years you've traveled the world
and
you already knew like oh here are the
places where we can explore these themes
and i already have these relationships
intact
yeah indeed there was a lot of things
and then some course corrections on the
fly too like iceland was like
almost a last minute thing and i
actually off camera i did some foraging
with some herbalists and stuff and so
really enjoyed that opportunity but
but yeah it was it was again like i had
lists of colleagues in every
episode like heavy right to your point
before
like if it was up to me it would have
been you would have gone down the
academic rabbit hole
a little heavier indeed yeah and the
thing about me when i travel
obviously i'm having fun
and so you know a little bit of the the
candor
from the show they grabbed a little more
than i probably
were comfortable with but but that's me
like so when i'm out and i'm on a
mission i also have the levity and the
in the lightness about it but i'm
absolutely committed
um so i had all of these experts on
every episode and we're going to
interview these people and that people
and dr
pollock and these water scientists and
uh blumenthal from american botanical
council
and we had uh andreas who was a head of
biopiracy that got caught out
like so there was there was a lot more
rigor of of intensity of information
and it was hard to be honest with you
the first the first actual episode we
shot was puerto rico and that was kind
of
flying to puerto rico
and realizing i have nobody on
my side in it that's what it felt like
because i didn't really yes i got to
know a lot of the producers beforehand
but then i'm like oh this is a this is
zach and he
he's a famous person and there's
intensity around that
and then realizing that like oh this
may not be getting all of the
information i want
right out and it was hard it was right
it was back in the
in the hotel after a couple days of
shooting and i was like
i don't know if i made the right
decision because well it looks like
it it feels like you went into this
thinking
i'm going to be the straight man and
zac's the entertainment and i'm the
educator here
but the way that it feels when i watch
it is almost like
zach's the straight man and you're the
one who's spinning a crazy yarn and he's
kind of looking you know breaking the
fourth wall and looking at the camera
like
is this for real with this guy you know
like he's the skeptic he's he's
traveling in the boots of the the
typical audience member who's never been
exposed to these ideas
and i think what makes it work is
is there is a bit of a vloggy kind of
youtube sensibility like there's a
comedians and cars aspect to this where
a lot of it is just you guys in the car
driving around right
and then it's laced with these beautiful
drone shots and you know incredible
cinematography and these montages
um and it picks its moments where it
gets serious but it's always
interspersed with these moments of
levity to you know
make it you know quote unquote like
entertaining yeah
and here's the thing all i will also say
over the years people said well if you
want to do a show you got to get a
celebrity
and i was like no i don't want to do it
bad enough yeah i i don't want to have
to do
that to make my topics what i believe
relevant relevant
so when i met zach and he
and this is very important because this
hit me and this
changed everything this was when he said
hey i have all these people that follow
me
i'm an actor but i want to do something
with my platform i want to make a
difference
i really want to you don't see me
hawking things on my platform you don't
see me selling stuff
i i'm that's for a reason and so i want
to do something that's going to move the
needle
on health on the planet on moving
towards a better
sustainable regenerative outcome for our
existence here and
i when he said it i believed it right
and that
that changed it all for me yeah meaning
that
number one it came this way he reached
out to me
so it wasn't me trying to find some
celebrity to
sell my show to it was this
innocent and powerful way that he wanted
to contribute
based on his where he is in his life
and he does care he's a very sweet
empathetic person that does care and
maybe just didn't know how to
do it until he saw a feather
or a line or a string in this connection
for us to be able to
start turning that corner to actually
make a difference and i think
i think it's a great start because it
you know for me it's never you've known
what i'm about it's never been about a
show it's about a movement it's about a
mission it's about
collaboration it's about really
doing something that will make a lasting
impact and i
i don't necessarily know how to do that
but i'm learning and i'm learning from
people what they're asking for so
so yeah i'm connected to a lot of things
the show
is is starting the conversation in a lot
of
ways and i am
excited to see what and how this unfolds
because i do not take it lightly
that something has sparked
this audience has entertained them
has dropped their defenses of being
talked
to about another
you know agenda-filled documentary
and listen we there's been a lot of
documentaries that have
you know it's hard even though the
subject matter you and i can agree with
but it's
it's sometimes hard to take because you
know
we can listen to it but it's not gonna
reach over the aisle and grab the other
people
yeah the show is a very you know deft
gentle
hand and i think the coolest part is how
it's connecting with really young people
like are you really gonna save you know
the dude that's our age who's set in his
ways and has his world view
at this point but if you can reach that
nine year old or that 12 year old and
get them thinking about these things at
that age when they're malleable
and they're just forming their opinions
about stuff it's incredibly powerful so
you know i just think it's cool and i
think you know to speak to zack a little
bit
um it's laudable that he would want to
use this massive platform and his
you know fame and celebrity for a good
purpose
and you and i can't fathom what it must
be like to be a guy like that who's been
just insanely famous for as long as he
can possibly remember
and when you're in that position
a like how do you even interface with
the world in a healthy way
and b like to the extent that like you
want to use it for good like
you know it's it's a really cool thing
like i i just i can't imagine what his
day-to-day life
existence is like yeah i mean you got a
glimpse of it traveling all over the
world with him
yeah you get a glimpse of it and it is
intense i mean
any country any city and he doesn't seem
to want any part of that
he's brilliantly gifted at what he does
but it's not about that for him
yeah yeah it's it's a interesting
relationship
yeah for sure because on the one hand
any celebrity will say of course there's
some great things about being a
celebrity
but man there is a there is
something about it on the intensity
scale
in terms of population and and what
people want from you
and that kind of energy that's
you and i can
walk around and be okay but when that's
always
almost anywhere yeah on the globe
like that and how do you trust anybody
yeah because everybody who rolls up on
you has some kind of weird agenda
yeah yeah and i think you know listen
that's
you know we we had a few moments in the
car where
and that's the cool thing about the show
eventually
i just you know for me i just didn't
care that the cameras were on
to try to be something we just they were
always on and then we were always just
had these great moments and there was a
couple times when i was driving from new
york
to the angry orchard apple uh situation
it was just this beautiful moment where
we just almost were having our own
moment and own little podcast in a sense
uh
and talking about his life and talking
about that intensity
and uh and yeah it's not
easy but i think through zach's not
afraid to dig in
and to look at you know where he has his
issues and where he struggles and
we all need to do that yeah of course um
so
i'm grateful for him
to open himself up in a
personal way and not being a character
not being a actor
and largely you know he was not that
comfortable
in the beginning of just like well oh
there's no
there's no script there's no it's just
us
and yeah well when you're an actor
you're inhabiting somebody else
yeah and this he has to be himself yeah
and
you know me turn the camera i got [ __ ]
to say you know
even though they took a lot of the weird
moments
but uh you know but but i think it's
it's
it's great to also see you know the
different parts of people because it
also
makes makes it real because i can i can
get very serious
about these subject matters and um
i have both sides where i can go in and
i have
strong opinions and everything else but
at the same
time in order for me to keep myself
balanced i have those you know
fun moments right that i i learned when
i traveled i've
seen a lot of things in the middle
of nowhere that are horrible like
when people you know when kids are dying
you're looking at these children
getting water for example in africa and
it's
feces-ridden water and you're like
that's their life every day and they're
dying of waterborne diseases and i'm
sitting there
talking to this village over here about
baobob in western africa about how we
can get that to a bunch of
people buying these supplements for
example
yeah it's a struggle but
how i remedy that is i take that very
seriously i
i've always taken that seriously and how
i remedy that
and wrestle with that is well how can i
benefit
these people how can i and we've talked
about this several times in terms of how
how to look at kind of trying to create
some sort of
you know whatever terminology uh you use
circular economy fair trade all of this
stuff
for me it's just the moral compass if
it's like
i see something wrong or not correct or
not
optimal how can i in in my own way
how can i help this situation and so
within that
within that world of seeing this it's
it's it's
easy to get overwhelmed with the amount
of
intensity we have with what we're not
doing great as humans
what we absolutely can improve and what
we absolutely
can improve in a great way that doesn't
have to be
detrimental on so many of these other
other directions from an environment
from a health perspective
there's no there's no separation between
the
our inner ecosystems and our outer
ecosystems and you know
our great friend zach bush talks you
know right speaks
wonderfully about that interaction and
so
and i think we need to as global
citizens we just
literally have to start thinking that
way and i also challenge companies to
start thinking that way like what is the
end product
of your container like all right
shouldn't you be responsible
for for what that's doing that
single-use plastic that's here for a
thousand years
maybe you should be responsible for for
that and maybe there's a currency that
we need to
tack on to or adjust or you know so
anyway i'm going down those rabbit holes
but that's
that's the view of the even the impetus
of this
show was like listen there is
a massive amount of stuff that we can
bring light to
how do you even start um
and the only way is like well let's
start here
and my life's not over and i have a lot
more to give
and maybe we get a second season maybe
we get a third maybe we just keep going
and
and maybe it proliferates into
bringing attention to a lot of other
things that aren't
having the right attention and
you know just one little thing on that
too like
i've always been you know like global
warming even having
that word or words
that becomes now political that becomes
you know black and white i don't even
like to use those words i just want to
like
go back to okay well if you can provide
clean power to a group of aboriginal
people
in the middle of australia i'm using
that example because we're working on
some projects there
and it doesn't cost the government 6.2
billion dollars to provide unsustainable
fuel for their generators that are
always breaking down this is
year by year by year by year by year but
if we can provide water
food power cleanly
why wouldn't we do it shouldn't we be
doing that i mean i think
that again the show is successful
because it doesn't take some kind of
partisan perspective but there is a
subtle
challenge to american exceptionalism
throughout the show because you go to
these other places that we as americans
might think
are underdeveloped in in comparison to
kind of the
technology that we produce for the world
and yet
they're so much more advanced than we
are in terms of how they're
approaching these very important
subjects a perfect example is going to
paris and seeing what they're doing with
their water and with the water fountains
and how
water is available to everybody and that
episode ends with
the statistics on single-use plastics
for water bottles and it's staggering
right and it makes you think like that's
something very basic that
we could and should be doing here and
we're not
and i think the more of those
experiences that you shine a light on
it makes us reflect on our own
you know flawed perception of
exceptionalism
as americans right yeah and i think
that's a
very powerful thing that some people who
may not
have gotten to travel and and don't get
to see
part of the world they're seeing these
amazing
people doing some incredible things that
we have gotten this delusion of
us as some sort of superior superpower
when yeah there might be things that we
do have
without a doubt but there's also
fatal flaws that we are still
doing in the face of profit-centered
economy
and that will always bite you in the ass
and so you know as simple as
just pulling the rug out from under this
this
single use bottle i mean of the 300
metric tons of plastic being created
every year
half of it is literally single-use
plastic
yeah it's just mostly water bottles
insane
so so we can absolutely start we need to
turn off that faucet
of of that insane idea
because you know not
one bit of the plastic that's ever been
created on earth
is gone you know it's still here
and that's up to 9.2 billion metric tons
of all the places that you went for the
sh what was your favorite
episode or location i've only watched
the first three
so oh man you're gonna get prepared that
last episode you're gonna cry
is that the one where your house burns
down yeah
um i cried both on the show
and often when i watch again but um
it's hard to know because they each had
this own special
um place i think
i mean iceland just from a personal
perspective
i wanted to just explore infinitely more
that certainly was and and you know then
you go to sardinia
and you see the true village
life centuries old
this simple way of living which is
flying right in the face of
everything that we've grown up with
and yet we're trying to reach back to it
to give us the gems so that we can live
long
yeah everybody in the village dating
back 500 years can be
traced to just five families i think
right yeah yeah yeah and uh
we we both got to one got cut out but i
i interviewed this hundred year old lady
too and i i literally could sit there
all day
the wisdom the just just pouring out of
these people not that they
are eloquently giving you the meaning of
life
but there's these simple con
it's this it's almost like
powerful contentment that you just
don't feel from
anybody it's just this i haven't
left my village i haven't this one lady
that i interviewed
that wasn't on the show she's never been
married
and i said really you just i didn't
think about it
what do you mean you didn't think about
it she was like i just was living my
life
and i didn't think about it i didn't
feel like i needed
a man and so it just never happened
and i was like wow
like she didn't buy into anything
because her village was also
not impressed upon these
made-up ideologies
it was this is the simple way of living
i'm content in such a degree i'm
blowing apart things that we think
we need to accomplish yeah and what is
the the half-life on those experiences
right like you've had many of these
over the course of your life but then
you come home
how much of that sits with you and
changes how you live on a daily basis
versus
you know fading away like that's the
trick
right you go and you're like we got it
all wrong look at what these people are
doing and then we go back and then we
just
do what we always do yeah yeah i think
that's a great point i mean largely i've
i mean you know i'm pretty
i'm pretty content in my in my now yurt
that i had to construct after the fire
and on the land and uh
under the trees so in one respect
all all in every trip that i've taken
has influenced me into into the kind of
life that i want
now at the same time i am pulled
and and drawn to contribute
and and leave something behind
whether it's education inspiration
connecting things and making certain
things possible
to contribute to things that i think we
need to on a bigger scale
whether that's health whether that's the
environment
that's the wrestle so i have a huge
desire
to contribute in that way
that's i wouldn't say i'm content with
that
right because i it's driving me
but i'm content in
saying yes to it i'm i'm it
it fuels me through you know
going back to like the the population of
people loving the show
i look at it as like yes keep coming
keep coming to what i'm doing keep
coming there are things that i'm
i'm creating that i can't reveal yet but
i am
not stopping and
i'm not okay with sitting
in swalelo in sardinia
becoming a hundred years right that's
not gonna work for you no that's not
your
that's not your blueprint no anyway it's
not my blueprint of the
the blue zones right but i think that's
also
the contentment of finding
you finding me finding what
what drives me not from an ego
perspective but
from um the heart
of you know the heart of everything i
want to do and it really comes down to
two
very simple things i care about
the health of people i believe a healthy
person has more choices
and can really kick ass in their life
and not have to drag around this body
and then be of
kind of this victim of a body that's
failing
so i believe in health of the individual
mentally emotionally physically
spiritually and i believe in the
intimate connection and the health of
the planet so if we can contribute
in those ways anything else you know me
anything else i just don't care
and those two things are interconnected
of course 100
and i think the show does a good job of
of establishing that and helping people
to understand that connection
and i think the only other thing that
i've gotten from it's
such a great question rich is the only
the
not the only other thing that an another
thing that i've gotten
from the travels is not only learning
more about myself
from the reflection of countless
different people around the world and
that is
a boundary to what works for me
and being completely cool with saying no
and this flies in the face of being kid
from minnesota i don't want to let
anyone down
yeah i know you well enough to know that
you like to say yes
and you got a lot of stuff over the
years you've got a lot of stuff flung in
your direction
and perhaps you said yes a little too
often to certain things
uh and now the volume is at 11 i would
suspect
what's coming at you so you gotta
definitely hone in your
no engine exactly yeah
yeah and stay focused and rather rather
than getting distracted chasing things
that
seem cool because everything is gonna
look like an awesome thing to do
right and you can't do it all so it just
makes it more important that you really
keep going back to what your core
mission is what your mission statement
is what your intention is
exactly i mean putting it through those
two cylinders
helps meaning the health of people
health of the planet
but then there's also what i'm just
really grateful for i've learned a lot
of
from people reaching out a lot of people
doing incredible things
to make the world not only on the show
itself
to see you know co2 sequestering
in iceland where they're injecting the
co2 back in the ground
and then it's creating rock and stone
and and
that's a great way to sequester some of
it
um yeah i like to also support
co2 sequestering from regenerative
agriculture that makes the most sense
and something that we can do right now
and
you know zach busch is doing great stuff
with farmer's footprint and all of those
things
those are the kinds of things that i i
want to want to
continue to support and and i've i've
learned
that there's you know there's a great
company called footprint
that is about a billion dollar business
that no one knows about
that is um supplying non-plastic
uh for single-use plastic alternatives
to the big boys
conagra uh pepsi mcdonald's like
they're scheduled to put out billions
of single-use items replacing
single-use plastic that to me
those kind of relationships from the
show
that fits with my mission right to to to
align
support be ambassador for and there's a
another
25 of them that i'm trying to do due
diligence on and
all of that stuff so so yeah it takes a
lot
and and um and there's a lot it's hard
it's hard to say no with things like
that for sure
we got to talk about lords yeah that was
a trip
yeah you go to lourdes and you're gonna
uh figure out what's going on with the
water there and the healing
and that episode opens up with a very
tricky
exchange with the the chief medical
doctor i don't know what his title is
right yeah
that got off to a rocky start and it
looked like
he thought you were gonna make fun of
him or something like like what was
happening there and like walk me through
that because then ultimately it
gets back on track and that was kind of
a mind-blowing thing that he
communicated yeah so
yeah that was a interesting
like there was so many different
directions to go down with water
from my scientist guys to which would
have been a little
dry and so i said well let's go to
lourdes
because i want to actually study
the water and there was a whole part
where i was
looking at the water and we didn't we
cut it out
and then i sent the water to dr gerald
pollock
for him to do and he wrote the book the
fifth phase of water he was an
incredible he's an incredible researcher
on water he's got a foundation
they're they're doing extensive research
he puts a
uh a program out every year and
the top scientists in the world so so i
was
number one i wanted to learn about what
the hell is going on
with this water and and so we ended up
at lourdes and i
so i didn't i knew the medical doctor
doctor existed
but i didn't want to meet him ahead of
time and so the people that i didn't
know
i didn't want to meet before the cameras
were on because i wanted to be
completely authentic
so and i don't want to throw on anyone
under the bus but
so the producers had set the meeting up
obviously we had to have an
official meeting and so this is what
we're going to do we're going to film
this and
you know one person's a actor the other
person is kind of
the the facilitator here of
water expert himself which they said um
and so we met him on camera
and i i instantly he i
when i met him i'm like oh i know that
kind of guy
like he's a brilliant wonderful
very articulate and very proud person
and very like i said underscore very
intelligent
and and so as so we met
cameras are rolling we shook hands and
uh he started it you know he sat back in
his chair
super excited to tell us a story you
know he had the
and so he started on the story and he
was a great order
and it was going to be a story and one
of the producers
as he started kind of stepped in
and said hey could you get to the part
where
blah blah blah and oh my god
he was insulted yeah
and i can understand both sides
i can understand he just started and we
set this up and so
so he was he was uh he went from
i love the guy by the way and i don't
hold any of that against him because of
a variety of things and he just went
from
zero to about a nine and a half
uh-huh being upset
and so i'm like this is we're done
meaning
he thought that
you were taking him seriously and this
might be some kind of weird hit piece or
yeah he he was starting in to really
tell us a story and he was interrupted
and then it just all triggered like what
am i what am i doing
i am legit i have a position that's real
i am a medically trained doctor and he
hadn't got to the point of how this
actually works right and how this
actually works was he
with all of his medical training and a
whole research
their their job is to figure out
if a miracle comes to them or someone
thinking that this spontaneously miracle
happened
his job was to figure out did it have
the criteria
that they could debunk that they could
figure well
you know it wasn't spontaneous and it
didn't completely
go under remission it didn't change and
there's all of our medical reasons
that didn't add up to this miracle so he
had a
so the science is heavy and
it's long and so as he was describing
starting he was trying to get there and
he got interrupted and
sure enough he was pissed and then i
realized in a nanosecond
that this guy's out he's out and zach
was like a deer in headlights and so he
was like holy [ __ ]
and everybody was and the producers were
in the other room it was just us and the
camera guys
and so i just go whoa whoa whoa i didn't
care about the camera i
i was like it was a little longer than
what we actually cut it to be and i just
like
let me back up this is who i am
i care about everything that you're
saying
and i want to learn screw the cameras
please tell me your story and so i just
i just reeled it back
and i said this is zach this is me i've
spent my lifetime in this
space of learning and exploring and
and i want to know what's going on here
at lourdes and i want to know what your
position is
on all of the stuff and and then he was
and then he sat back
calmed down bam right and that changed
everything and the producers were like
we don't know how you did that
but thank you yeah and and it became
and then of course in the episode they
showed the x-rays the mirror it's
right and just to recap for people that
are watching are listening lords is this
place in france where people have been
going for you know
hundreds of years to uh
to bathe themselves and imbibe this
water uh for that's lauded for its
healing properties dating back to
bernadette having this vision of the
mother mary
and being compelled to dig up this
essentially like underground spring and
so over the years there are all these
documented cases of people going there
and being healed
so you go there and say explain to me
what's going on here you meet with this
doctor
and he's showing you x-rays and mris of
cases that he has vetted over the years
where there's no
legitimate scientific explanation for
how these people have healed themselves
other than the fact that they have
come to lourdes and participated in this
ritual of bathing in this water
yeah yeah this spring has been flowing
ever since
and people drink it they bathe in it
they come
clearly there's an energy there you have
it feels like a sacred place i mean it's
just
and that guy had like massive had a
massive cancer growth in his hip right
that just ate away his entire hip bone
yeah so that was the one that he showed
us
that was one of the latest miracles they
had
decades of research a stack of research
papers
trying to figure out how this happened
the guy himself apparently didn't
believe in the miracle or anything but
he
he bathed in it and started tingling all
over
and his
hip was a it was mush there was
nothing but ligaments holding his hip
together because it
the cancer just had eaten uh his
right side of the hip completely and
it all regenerated and there is zero
scientific evidence for them
to explain it right and so what happens
is once they've
hit these certain criteria then they're
like
we can't explain it in any way
in our modern medicine from every angle
from all the researchers who can't
explain it so then they pass it
to the parish to the church
and they're like it's now up to you
whether you so it's not the doctor's
decision his job is to try to debunk it
he runs it through this
calculus of these criteria um one of
which is
uh that it has to stand the test of time
right like so they they look they
continue to like study these people for
like a decade
after they visit lourdes and they have
to dismiss any other rationale for why
this person was healed and
can't ever come back right
yeah it's so crazy man yeah
wow yeah so so lourdes was
this place we could go to to start the
conversation
that many many i've met hundreds of
scientists that have dedicated their
lives to understanding this mystery
this mystery of water and
it has so many properties we talked
about we did like a whole podcast on
water
yeah and it goes deeper and like pun
intended it goes deeper and deeper and
deeper and deeper
um so lurids was this
opportunity for us to go there is
a form a structure
a quantum expression a chemical
expression
a biological expression an influence
that water has and
receives and transmits and transports
and
everything from conduction of voltage
which we
live on which our cells are
are needed a certain voltage
we need in order to have healthy cells
so
and you're thinking about okay well all
cells are
through an osmotic flow of
inertial water and extra tissue water so
so there's a osmotic flow and then when
you talk about i mean just touching on
this again
because it's so fascinating when you
talk about which is why
i love dr gerald pollock's work when
that water touches a
hydrophilic surface like the cell
membrane
it creates energy
from coming up against that surface by
exchanging protons and
and electrons by pushing them out
creating that what's called an exclusion
zone a little thin layer in between
the the the membrane and the water
itself
and you're like what it's creating
voltage
it's creating energy just
by the water coming up against the
surface
so that exploration is a continuous you
know this about me
it's a continuous exploit exploration of
what the hell is water and how
it's structured and how it can be
influenced and how it
can hold ridiculous amounts of
memory physical memory like a hard drive
a computer
it can transmit information it can
receive
information so so lures going back to
the show
lourdes was dipping our toe
in a little bit
of what potentially
water can kind of be
um and you took that water and you had
it studied
yeah that didn't make it into the show
but what were the results of that
well there's i mean it's so hard to so i
tested it from total dissolved solids
so it had a had a great medium
mineral content you don't want too much
so there wasn't
anything profound there wasn't any
toxins
that i saw there wasn't heavy metals
there wasn't
there wasn't environmental issues
um and exposure from our modern day
world there wasn't a lot so it was the
spring it was clean it wasn't
you know so there wasn't that negative
side of it
there was a slightly positive
ph to it so it wasn't acidic so it was
benefiting so when you look at
ph you're also looking at voltage so
when you have a negative voltage
you have a a electron
[Music]
giving situation if you have a acidic
situation you have
you have like call it a free radical you
have a scavenger
you have a scavenger trying to take from
in the body and when you have a negative
voltage
you have an antioxidant essentially so
that's a very
quick version so so from the ph
perspective it was like okay that makes
sense it's
it's it's balanced uh it's got
electrolytes
and then i sent it off to dr pollock
unfortunately through
you know i put it in a stainless steel
jug i sent it through but it's so hard
because
because it's now being influenced by all
the other frequencies
by the airline trip and so
so he looked at it we didn't get
conclusive evidence whether it had
a lot of these hydrophilic properties
or so it you know
there wasn't anything that immediately
jumped out to you that said this is
different than any other water i've ever
seen and
yeah there's some kind of alien entity
yeah but that being said this was a very
crude way of looking at yeah there was a
lot
of there's a lot more science you could
look into that
um from i think pollock would go right
to the source and test it there
he he he has over the years been in
touch with this doctor
so there's been a lot of the top
scientists and
from their perspective there is
something going on with the water i
i don't know what that is yet but uh
there has to be some sort of control
of it it's not gonna work by me putting
in a thing and and
sending it off to dr pollock and having
some super molecule
that uh is in there so but but it it
begs the question
there there is without a doubt coming
from the earth
an aquifer that is still flowing
naturally from from the source
from the earth itself it's obviously a
better water period but the
miraculousness
i would love to find out in my lifetime
yeah how they how that actually
occurs yeah well it's crazy times
you got ufos being legitimized and all
kinds of stuff
so who knows man um let's talk about
your house burning down i mean i think
if memory serves me
when we last did the podcast you had
just recently
acquired the property and moved in i
think
on the timeline yeah so you bought this
incredible um little hunting lodge that
had been there when was it built
1933 yeah on this pristine beautiful
patch of untouched land deep in the
hills outside of malibu um
and this was like like a dream
right to come into this place and while
you were shooting the show
the woolsey fire happens and
just i mean you were right in the thick
of it like
right where the the brunt
of the fire just just rushed right over
your property and everything was
scorched
yeah yeah
finishing the last episode
you know right so i was in the amazon
finishing this show
and i knew that the i knew that the fire
had
started and then
we were on the amazon and we had no cell
reception
so i was just like well my house has
been around for a while
so i'm i'm betting on longevity
so you had heard were you completely out
of touch or you had heard that a fire
had
started yeah so i could fire a malibu
yeah so i had heard from
my neighbors and from other people in
malibu hey there's a fire
and and i was like okay uh i'm
sending good vibes man um my house is
ultimate you know lesson in
powerlessness
completely and a little naive because
i'm like i don't know how big it is i
don't really know
much about it but i'm like you know fire
in malibu unfortunately is
uncommon yeah so
i was off uh we were in the amazon we
had a lot of exploring to do and largely
just when i think about it i just send
good vibes and
and then we were
done in the amazon the funny thing is
when you do the timeline if people are
watching the show the last episode
there's a plate where we're doing a
cleansing ceremony we're smoking
so with all these herbs not ayahuasca
not hallucinogens just
just kind of think of it as like a sage
ceremony where it's cleansing your aura
and negative energies and just a
very it was a very powerful moment
and when we looked at the timeline
the pretty much exactly the time that
that was going on
and i was being smoked out is when my
house was burning
how crazy is that i just didn't know it
whoa so on some level
i'm being smoked out getting to this
incredible
beautiful meditative place while
almost exactly my house is literally
scorched
and burning so we
leave and jump back on the boat
going down the amazon river next thing i
know
we get back to aquitos the boat ramp
and i literally turned on my phone
and i had hundreds of messages
and then within about five minutes i
realized and there was pictures from my
neighbor
and i mean it was an incredibly
challenging thing like we just had been
in the middle of the jungle we just had
all of these things going on
and then not five minutes
i wasn't even off the boat and i'm
sitting there stunned
and then i literally we get in the car
and i'm like my house just burned down
my i'm shocked
and i called my neighbor was the first
person i said and they picked up and i
was like
and as soon as they answered
they said i'm so sorry and i was like
yeah but what was there
what i'm so sorry
what happened i'm so sorry everything
what do you mean everything i'm so sorry
all of my my house my car my everything
i'm so sorry
you need to call your insurance company
and i'm
and then they sent pictures that they
had walked down
and taken and i saw
and that moment was just you can't
you can't understand it yeah in that
moment so
i mean only your fireplace remained
and your truck just literally melted
yeah
and motorcycles and barns right and
uh so i received pictures and i
and then i was in the middle of just
devastation like i didn't
and then i hearing all these messages my
mom left messages my ex-wife left
messages all these people leaving i'm so
sorry and i'm like i'm trying to
process like what do you mean i just
lost everything like
and then and then i told the crew
and then a few hours later they said
let's listen we totally understand if
you want to leave
and go deal with this stuff and i just
sat there and i was like well
what am i going to do what am i going to
do now
and so i just said well
why do you think i'm here
i'm i'm here on this mission that may
look
partially like a tv show
but there was a moment in puerto rico
that
didn't make the show there was a point
when the
when i said that was the first place we
shot when i was looking around at the
devastation
that happened in puerto rico from the
hurricanes
and i looked and they're putting up you
know they're putting up the same
infrastructure that's going to get wiped
out again without a doubt it doesn't
take a rocket scientist to figure that
out
and i'm like you guys might have power
after a year and a half
but you're as vulnerable there's no
difference and
and then i was like i'm looking around
going that's the same infrastructure we
have everywhere
we're all vulnerable it could happen to
all of us any of us
and that was literally conscious thought
from puerto rico and then it literally
happened to me
i lost everything from a disaster
like this and so
that resolve of why i'm here
became very clear very quick even though
i'm grieving and i'm sad and i'm upset
and i'm shocked and i was like i'm not
leaving
i'm finishing this [ __ ] show like
because i know
at least a glimpse more of why
i'm doing this why i'm even here
and so i didn't leave and we continued
with the show and
and then i you know i came back and then
dealt with just waves and waves and
waves of grief
i reached out to dylan and asked him i
said darren's coming on the podcast like
what are some things that happened
during the filming of the show because
dylan was on the production team
that you know i might not know about
that would be interesting to explore and
he said
he he gave me a lot of input but
basically one of the things he said was
that
you know definitely when his house
burned down when you guys were in
aquitos
he said that was so tragic but somehow
darren kept his head on his shoulders
and filmed and stayed positive
he was a rock the whole shoot always a
morale booster for
the exhaustive the exhausted crew we
definitely looked up to his work ethic
his early morning workouts and constant
positivity
and knowledge bombs and you know the
fact that like you just lost
everything that you own like your
relationship to the material world was
completely rocked
while you're being saged in this place
where people have
nothing and your ability to maintain
your composure
of course amidst of you know the
emotional tumult that that would have
caused
is an incredible thing and you know
i just know knowing you how you
navigated the kind of emotional
landmines of that
and the very practical material
and very quickly you went from you know
look
anybody would be horribly upset at this
happening but
you were able to reset really quickly
and reframe the entire thing
as an opportunity and you were able to
let it go
like true not just give it lip service
but to like really like let it all go
so like walk me through that like
journey you know when you come back
and you have to see what has happened to
the point of like
this is awesome now i get to like build
the house that i want
i think that um
you know grief is not something that
comes easy
for anybody and uh the loss is so
intense that i think the
the the practice
of challenges
helped prepare me for that
that moment and the only other thing i
could relate to that was
more intense than that was the loss of
my father
and when my father passed away
it was so incredibly intense that i just
told myself
let it all happen let the emotions
happen
don't try to do anything i don't know
where that voice came from
so i did i let all of that emotion go
and i and and process through me and the
same thing with the house
i i can't hold this tsunami of emotions
back
it physically hurts to try to
intellectualize
what just happened so let it happen
let it all express itself
and it was weird rich it was tricky
because the whole community got hammered
yeah friends of mine and friends of
yours and and
so when i was grieving through it
and realizing that i have friends i have
relationships i have love
that was the first thing that came
rushing through
and the support and the love and the
their hands reaching out to me was
from every direction that was like well
this is what it's all about this is life
right here and so receiving that was a
gift
and and then through that grief
and allowing it to happen it was just
like well
it may feel like this happened
to me but something shifted and i was
like
no this happened for me
and then once that clicked i got so
elated it was
freaky i know it was weird because you
were lit you were legitimately
like thrilled and i was like what is
going on
i know this is incredible i know when
you guys were looking at me like an
alien but it clicked into
there's gonna be a lot of work ahead
yeah i wasn't that wasn't
you i mean you're you're in the yurt now
you've been in the year for longer than
i
thought you would be in the yurt like i
thought your this new house project
would be
further along than it is i don't know
what the status is but it's still in
permit
hell but i went to this is happening to
me
no this is happening for me yes and
the thing that it did was
the glimpse that i got into my resolve
when i thought i was passionate about
contributing to the world
and contributing to people and
contributing to helping the planet
i paled in comparison to what this
deepened inside of me
so that gift alone
i could not take that back i would not
want to take that back
because it gave me
i don't know what even call it this
sense of
commitment love respect
resolve passion all of that deepened
in a way that there's no way i would
want to give that back so
i wouldn't want that experience not to
have
happened because of the gift that i was
starting to receive and waves and waves
and waves
and you guys and you seeing some of that
stuff i was like
i'm freaking stoked man because i
see something now i see through
the grief and i see a world that i want
to contribute to
and i know that i can
kick some ass and give it a go and
use this as an opportunity to
raise attention about a different way
of decentralizing power for example
there's
people i know that can create clean
power in a powerful way build
differently that can protect against
fire and seismic activity of earthquakes
that we can regenerate through
permaculture and understanding
food and food systems and growing
through our connectedness
of this earth are the way we're living
and the way we're not living and their
health
and vitality
[Music]
all of that stuff was rushing in in a
way that i thought i knew
but was coming in so powerfully
that i changed my life and
i'm grateful for it so living in the
year no problem
yeah still going for more it's more you
anyway than a hunting lodge
you know what i mean you're living in
this yurt so you have this kind of
minimalistic lifestyle and at the same
time the project
of reimagining and reconstructing
a domicile for you is
like a project and a symbol and
a means for you to bring your your
values into greater
alignment with your actions right like
you can create this structure that
reflects everything about who you are
being off the grid and with the water
and with the power and all that kind of
stuff
uh but you're also butting up against
the status quo in a big way like i know
you've this battle that you're
waging right now just to just to try to
create something that is off grid
is something no one wants to hear about
right like you're like i don't want to
use the power from the pole i'm going to
do it this way and they're like well you
can't
right like this the systemic nature of
how we live is so
powerful that it almost doesn't permit
you to do things a better way
yeah and then and quote unquote the
normal person
has no other options right because we
haven't invested
into our world that way we have been
reliant upon these
monolithic monopolies that are like okay
if i build a house
i gotta use this company edison or
pg e or these other big monopolies and
they
put up these god-awful polls and they
string these lines
and it clicks through a house and then
we have a smart meter that blasts us
with emf
and blah blah goes on and on and on and
i was like
number one these freaking guys didn't
give me temporary power they had me
jumping through all these freaking hoops
so i just said screw you guys i'm not
taking your power i'm gonna
create i'm gonna build a yurt i'm gonna
get it off grid i'm gonna use solar
panel i'm gonna use
some battery systems and i'm going to
have everything i need
it's not i'm not living without a air
conditioning
and beautiful bathroom and yeah it's a
nice yurt
yeah i'm i'm going to live and i'm going
to i'm going to also
explore that we don't have to live
not that there's anything wrong with it
like we're delivering
just in a tent without
these beautiful parts of our modern day
world where it's comfortable
and clean and all of that stuff
i want to put attention that we can
decentralize this power
because i'm not taking power
from any monopoly ever again
i'm not take so when i build the the
beautiful
sustainable house the one that's
gorgeous and looks like a piece of art
and has all of this
stuff in it i'm not living in a tent
i'm living in a beautiful structure i'm
never taking power again
so there's other ways and it's way
beyond solar
and this is a whole other conversation
that you and i will have
when i start really getting into these
power systems that will blow people's
minds
again that people are doing that we
don't know about a little bit on this
show like you realize there's some great
people and countries doing incredible
things if we knew more about that stuff
we could as a populace invest
and understand and educate ourselves
around that and not have these
monopolies
largely being the result of this
fire right for example that
changed our community forever so
no i'm going to spend time energy and
resources into
decentralizing decentralize our food so
it can
be food sovereignty decentralize our
power so we can have power sovereignty
and and start to
figure out different ways to cultivate
water
right and there's ways believe me
there's ways that you can cultivate from
two percent humidity and you can create
drinkable water right now uh there's a
lot of different things that we can do
to create freedoms back again
because i don't know about you but
there's some freedoms
for some good reasons for right now
and some not good reasons that are going
on as we speak
that are not promoting our freedom
so i don't need to be the subtle ones
that we're not even consciously aware of
that they're
that are the ones that are more
problematic that we need to pay more
attention to and i think the power thing
is a great example of that i mean i
remember i came down to your house to
visit you
maybe a year ago or something like that
and it was an ongoing frustration
because they wouldn't give you temporary
power right like
i don't know what was going on there but
i i go to your house you don't have
temporary power but
it was either i think it was edison had
brought all its trucks down and they're
like trimming
the trees around the poles where the
wires were and you were like
i was like what are these guys doing
here you're like you went out there and
you were livid you're like
i don't even have power here i don't
want your power what are you doing here
cutting my trees like get off my
property
totally do you remember that i remember
that the timing of you
you were like behind the trucker so
stuck like because you have this tiny
little winding
i mean to get to where you live is like
a whole ordeal right
and you there's no there isn't room for
a car to pass another car on your
winding long driveway that was a funny
moment
that because that was the culmination of
them
not giving me power when i desperately
needed to be back on my property
so everything that la county and malibu
county
basically said they were going to do
they weren't doing
um and so i'm fighting with going
they're not wow they're not going to
give me temporary i can't inhabit my own
property
so the very i'm jumping through hoop
after hoop after they want this now they
want this now they want this now they're
making me do all these things i'm like
give me
[ __ ] temporary power i want to be
back on my property
i want my dog back who's like displaced
and can't be with me right now give me
my life back
and i bureaucratically they didn't care
so that moment was a funny moment when
you
showed up and i'm like they just rolled
into my property
didn't tell me and started cutting down
sacred oak trees for wires
that weren't even turned on right so i
raced
back i called them immediately
saying tell me that these wires are not
don't have power
okay hold on we'll get back to you they
yes they don't have power they're not
turned on okay great
take your power lines down i've never
told you it's okay
get them off my property and also these
people
are cutting my trees down get them out
of here
so i think we all can relate
to that we all have this beautiful
convenient world
but there's you know i use this term all
the time there's fatal conveniences
in this respect if my power goes out
i have no power sovereignty if i rely on
these things
monopolies and these systems that are
failing they failed puerto rico
they failed me they failed our community
we have to do something different we
have to do everything
we can pun intended to get our power
back
our individual power we need to invest
into these other systems that do not
have it all intertwined with one or two
people making decisions for
everybody yeah power just being power
being more than just
electricity but a symbol of personal
agency
100 in our lives yeah yeah how has
uh the age of covid and coronavirus
affected your daily routine like what's
it would walk me through
the daring olean day in the life of
hydration and nutrition and fitness
i mean obviously the intensity of the of
the moment
um doesn't escape us yeah but my daily
my daily life is largely not
different you're as socially distant
from other people as anybody i know yeah
i mean just where
geographically where you live yeah and
it's also part of
understanding how i
work powerfully in the world i do need a
sense i
do need nature i do need to repower
myself up
i do need to step away in order for me
to
to then step in and and kick some butt
um but yeah the so i'm grateful i've
cultivated a life where i
don't have i'm not right not i'm not
next to people in buildings and
wi-fi signals and that intensity so
my heart goes out to people in this
challenging time where you're like
stuck i'm not
and with that i don't look at that
lightly i'm trying to do
i'm as busy as i've ever been i'm as
structured
and as scheduled as i've ever been
and because i want to contribute i want
to
continue to help people live a healthier
life so i wake up i
wake up early i you're on the eight to
four
program still yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
for sure um so you know i i
get my my water action i i start
you know got my he's got some
show-and-tell i got my blue bottle
so this is a great company this is where
glass bottles get away from single-use
plastic i've
i filter my water like crazy all the
water filters into my house
this is a cool company because of the
frequency of the blue
um the light passing through the blue
does what to the wall helps structures
the water in a way that's a similar
um frequency as a healthy cell so
healthy cell
is between negative 25
and 35 microvolts right so that light
passing through helps to structure that
water it creates a
energetic signature that is similar to
that which is a healthy cell
okay when you get injured the body uses
more energy to
ramp up the voltage literally so that
the
healing can happen when you're acidic
and not eating well and not eating
enough plants
your voltage literally drops right
eighth grade uh class took to voltage
meters
in a potato and you turn a light on
right that's as simple as it is
right so boom drink my water i've got
some hydro on demand hydrogen water
what's the name of that
bottle this is a company called blue
bottle love mm-hmm
and i happen to have love on the bottle
so this works with
you know dr emoto masuriya moto right
yeah exactly so he did a lot of research
around
the structure of water and this was just
his way of showing that their water is
is uh informed right so he wrote
the you know love and hate and all of
this stuff and realized that that
water is structured by that influence
so hey whether you believe it or not
feels good to look down and drink water
that's
filled right you know that's that's
bathing in love
and then i also have uh you know so i
have a lot of technology around
uh water but then what is your
particular water
filter filtration system that you use
yeah so i
filter all the water um
coming into the house so every bit of
water
goes through three phase filters um
and then it vortates so
the great work of schauberger back in
the early 1900s he was an observer and
researcher of
of of nature and he realize that water
vortades it's healthy when it structures
itself that doesn't
move in a straight line nor is it good
when it's stagnant
so my water is filtered and then it
goes through a vortainer so it
structures the water as it's coming into
the house
and then i it's just a nice little ro
system so reverse osmosis so it's taking
out
pharmaceuticals taking out fluorides and
chlorines and
volatile compounds that interact with
those things
and then i have a then my final
um filter system it goes to
into an on-demand hydrogen create a
crating machine so
hydrogen is uh one of the great
antioxidants
um stabilizers of free radicals in
nature
so that's pretty much what this is and
then it's in
so it's literally like a three stage
four stage
process where you have multiple
filtration systems before the water ends
up in that blue bottle
yeah plus i have a well too so what well
is
pretty and you get all the water from
the well yeah right
and uh so yeah it's pretty so my whole
people that are
into digging into that morty of links
for
the particular types of filters that you
use that we could put in the show notes
we're devising a
uh faq because that's a big big uh well
after your water episode on the show i'm
sure
a lot of people want to know more we'll
get that to you and um
if people are overwhelmed with just
hearing that yeah i mean
you basically just a reverse osmosis
a couple hundred bucks that's is that
the most important of all of these like
if somebody wants to just start
like where's the focus yeah because the
ro is a
particular size of filter that won't
allow those particulates to go
go through the dangerous ones the
pharmaceuticals and the
the things that are ending up in our
water so it filters out that or you can
also
distill the water so distillation
through
evaporation and then recondensing
clearly that's a good one but your water
sommelier in the show said no bueno to
that
yeah so that's where him and i conflict
a bit
and we weren't able to to
have a discussion enough that would make
it in the show
so so here but he's not wrong
there's just some nuance to it not
everyone can buy
a bottle water from
who knows where right but some of those
so let's define tds again total dissolve
solids in our modern day world
there's a lot of junk as a total
dissolved solid
there's pharmaceuticals there's chlorine
there's fluorides
there's volatile nitrates there's a
bunch of stuff
so the tds number alone is not a valid
indicator
because it doesn't it doesn't calibrate
the quality of the tds right
it's exactly it's just a total if in
nature it was just tds it would just be
mainly minerals right unless some dirt
was in there
so tds is important
but it's important not to have the
volatile compounds if you turn on your
tap
you're having many of those followed
compounds now the good thing about the
modern day world you're putting chlorine
in there so it can make it all the way
to you
and not have bacteria that literally is
going to kill you
so that's there's nothing wrong with
what we've done
but it hasn't got out everything and by
exposing yourself to those chemicals and
and those interactive volatile compounds
those are what you need to strip out so
so
so that's the distinction difference
between tds
so super high tds that he obviously
showed on the
show that is not a sustainable way of
getting hydration those are just
incredible
kind of um almost medicinal
sides of water that are just there to
to facilitate something and be exposed
to but not
on a long term way to be hydrated
definitely not so you and
for the most part none of us have free
exposure to clean
spring water number one if you have
clean
tested spring water number one choice
without a doubt
but most of us don't which is why i then
go well you have to deconstruct
that water you got to get rid of that
crap
so that you can build it back up again
which is why i say distill your water
and reverse osmosis and then
you can like re-mineralize it so then
you can re-mineralize it and a pinch
of himalayan crystal salt does what it
adds the
minerals and the electrolytes again for
what
so voltage can happen because
that is how you hydrate and that is how
you
maintain healthy cells so again you go
back to voltage you go back to frequency
if you have distilled water has no
voltage
right so that's just where that little
pinch so that's the easy thing for
people do
ro distill add a pinch of himalayan
crystal salt
and then if you want to start exploring
stay away from single-use plastic
start to get maybe a little into the
structuring side of
of the water help to influence that
water a little bit
shake it up uh maybe get a little more
oxygen
oxygenation in there um
water doesn't like to be just sitting
around so
um yeah so that's a little bit on all
right what to do so
so so anyway that's it always seems to
be the long part of the my morning
routine is water
but hydration is your whole thing i mean
the the point being like we're under
hydrated
if people truly understood the power the
potency the importance of hydration
it could really revolutionize your
health yeah i mean
one of the number one cause of fatigue
uh retention uh brain loss the
dementia and alzheimer's definitely have
a dehydrative component
to that when you look at the stats
i even mentioned this in my book seven
percent of 300 million people
don't even drink an ounce of water a day
rich
that's like how is that possible i know
because because what's happened what i
believe is happening
when you wake up your body has used that
waters trying to repair the brain and
the central nervous system and
and get out the toxins you wake up
you're fatigued you're
tired you reach for what you think
you need energy force you reach for your
coffee your stimulants and everything
else and then you're in that cycle
but you're not actually reaching for
water and so
the the brain and the being is so
powerful that it will
shut off that signal of just intense
thirst
so that you can actually have enough
mental capacity to primarily
try to find water again but we're not
we're grabbing for the other stimulants
again
so it's it's a it's a crazy thing the
the
the body's so adaptive that we literally
literally will pass on dehydrated
blueprints epidemiologically to your
children
because if you have trained yourself
that this is a desert i'm not drinking
any water
then your body has to shut down certain
systems
the skin's definitely gonna start to
fail your eyesight your brain activity
is gonna be less you're gonna be
fatigued
and if you've been doing that you're
gonna pass that on to your children
epigenetic way you mean yeah yeah yeah i
mean if you take one thing away from
this podcast
it's start your day with a liter of
water 100
yeah yeah so then you know from there i
just play
a lot of elixirs and and
uh adaptogens and things like that and
then i have my morning routine and
uh you know i get very clear on what i
want to do and
my passions and alignments and
meditative places i go to
uh breathing routines uh may seem like a
lot but it isn't it's very efficient
and then and then it's just getting
clearer on
what i want to do and then i work out
and
that's a lot of by the time you finish
the morning workout you've lived an
entire day
yeah you get up at four this process
begins
and and by 10 a.m
you're ready to start your day but
you've already had a whole day yeah so
that's when i'll take
like make maybe make a ridiculously huge
bowl of
like um fruit
and smoothie and throw a ton of baruches
on top
and that's when i'll have my first meal
after i've done all that you know
and you live alone with chaga your dog
so you
have the ability to control your
environment in a way that a lot of
people don't
um how was it when you were doing the
show
and you had to go to all these crazy
places like i gathered from
at least in iceland trying to
trying to try to eat plant-based there
looked like it might have been a little
bit of a challenge
yeah i mean you do realize throughout
you know
all of these traveling around you
realize that certain cultures it's a lot
more difficult
but you know luckily the word was out so
all these people and chefs and like they
made sure that
it wasn't it wasn't challenging um
but yeah i mean it's i don't make it a
big deal
when people want to eat whatever they
want that's that's on them right
i thought it was interesting in the show
the point is made like oh you're vegan
but
it's not belabored it's not about that
and you're not
like trying to you know make that at the
forefront of
of you know what the show is about
specifically
yeah i mean listen i you know i've
talked i i just want to lead by
an example and also demystify that you
can live a healthy strong
life um
eating plants yeah i mean you know it's
ridiculous that
that is not perceived even
that you know you can get all the
nutrients you want
from infinitely more so
i don't like to hammer that in people
but um
i i still kick
ass yeah and love it well you out
sprinted zach out in the field in france
yeah yeah and this tm's this time how
did the plant-based diet rub off on him
listen he's been in and out of that for
a while i think it's just
uh you gotta commit man you gotta commit
to anything
and you know you know being an ad this
isn't exact comet per se but i've been
around a lot of actors and and you go in
and
out of these micro worlds and and
it can be draining if you don't prepare
and plan
uh in and out of this intensity then you
can flip and flop
all the time you know i saw it in my
wife too
my ex-wife as an actress so
so you know he flips and but you know he
believes in plants and
medicinal plants and and for sure and he
largely
um has been eating uh a lot of plants
and
and mostly plants but you know i think
for the show he felt a little pressure
too to like well the chefs and they're
gonna make us all the stuff so i should
you know yeah yeah yeah what else you
got in your show and tell down there you
got some verrucas
oh my god dude so
these have never
um so this isn't even the right bag
notice i put cacao
i'm gonna have you guys right you wrote
it in pen so this is the last time you
were on the podcast this company had
essentially
recently launched beruka's the uh the
peru nut
company that are these incredibly
delicious nutritious nuts that you've
sourced from the serratu
in uh in brazil and these things are
unbelievably delicious
yeah you can't believe how good they
taste and then when you look at their
nutritional profile it's insane it's
insane
so this dude is that your body this
this is the new butter so they so they
we put a wild cashew with baruches
before and i told them listen give me
some time
let me make a butter i want you to try
that yeah
slide that over i want you to try that
that is
the best so that's coming out
that is a baruka butter with
a little coconut oil coconut oil
cinnamon no it's got the fruit
of the baruches in there that's the
crunchy stuff
and then a little bit of lohan gao which
is called monk fruit
so it adds a little extra sweet to it so
that's coming out very soon probably
when this launches
yeah and then this oh my god so you're
going to mass produce this
yeah those are from the factory in
brazil i made it so much better
than peanut butter or almond butter
coconut oil brew nut
and the fruit fruit and the and the
fruit of the baruches
right it's like wow perfect combo
so this try some of those so now this is
fair trade cacao
covered oh my god so these are
it's it's this is the this is the
superfood equivalent of chocolate
covered peanuts
oh yeah man and it tastes infinitely
better
those are holy [ __ ] wow those are
crazy so for anyone who doesn't know
the baruch is one of those
companies where i you know i found this
nut
it was basically offered to me
and said do you know about it no i don't
i looked into it i explored it
i saw the nutritional profile i actually
didn't believe it
because it was so superior than any nut
that's ever been tested so
we tested it got our own nutritional
data
blew all the nuts away complete protein
uh three times more fiber 400 percent
more antioxidants than almonds
it's a wild food it's very rare
to be eating wild food these days right
so it's naturally collected throughout
the sahara
supporting all these indigenous foragers
not just supporting them but basically
creating a a buffer
like a preventative zone to to compete
against the encroaching
cattle ranchers who want to clear this
land yeah and also
going back to the cattle ranchers that
also have it going hey we'll give you
trees to plant some of these back so
that you have shade for your cattle
and so we're starting to starting to
those conversations
so it supports the people it supports
people by eating it because it's so
nutrient dense it's
delicious and we're planting trees and
also
other biodiverse plants in the sahato
again
because the sahada people don't realize
it's being destroyed faster than any
land mass
on the planet so for unsustainable we
don't hear a lot about the sahara we
hear about the amazon
i know but the sahara is like a it's
more
it's a drier kind of plane-like
environment right yeah so most of the
the the plant
biomass is underground biomass is
underground so
you have these this uh the the bado zeta
tree
has got a very deep taproot and that's
where the barucha comes from and it taps
the aquifer below so it doesn't need
this auxiliary water so this is all
again it's wild there's no
pesticides herbicides there's no uh
irrigation inputs it's from the wild and
so
we're getting getting to support that
natural biome
and then actually help planting the
trees so every
so our basic motto is every five pounds
we sell we plant
we plant a tree and so we're we're super
proud of that
and um and getting this out and again we
we
this is this is again a no-brainer we
had to
create our business model this way and
this is where we all have to go
you know in supporting the people
supporting the environment and
supporting the customers that are
getting a nutrient
right dense food the trick with these
things is
they come encased in a massive shell
like the fruit right
it's unbelievably hard and you have to
like essentially
historically they've done this one by
one right
by hand yeah and the trick is trying to
figure out a way to
scale this so that you can like devise
some kind of machine to do it or how
what's going on with that yeah so we're
still i mean we've made
progress but we're still trying to
continue to develop
better and better mechanisms to crack
that shell you can't use existing
nut cracking because different sizes
different kind of shell we're shaving
the fruit from the outside and using the
fruit
it's just but historically they used to
thousands of years ago they take the
whole fruit
so when i say the whole fruit it's got
the fruit layer it's got the shell it's
got
one seed right one per per
thing yeah and you can unbelievably
labor intensive for one seed
and you can't pick it early it has to
fall because it doesn't actually develop
the seed until at the
very end and so they pick it up and
typically they put it around a fire and
and then on the outside of the firewood
it would roast it
overnight and then it was easier to
break open than they would eat it
but but when we showed up they were like
hitting them with
rocks and machetes and
and things like that so we've started to
automate
using hydraulics and other things like
that so we're continuing to develop
um but yeah it's it's it's
creating an economy that was largely
these doors were being lost i mean these
people are shutting their doors to this
this even within the country so we're
super proud that we
have have allowed for this indigenous
plant
to still be around and then to develop
it
in the country itself because we're very
happy that we're starting to distribute
all throughout brazil
too it's not just yeah bring it here and
let's sell it you know we're selling it
all throughout what about the trail mix
did you bring any of that oh i didn't
oh the trail mix is so good yeah sorry
so the trailer it's also like a
an amazing breakfast cereal it's
unbelievable 100
so the trail mix for everyone listen is
the nut
with the fruit layer that's dried and we
add it together and it's just a
ridiculous combination
can is this this is basically like
direct to consumer right now i mean it's
in some retail outlets that's right but
yeah we're following the website yeah
the website's there baruch.com and then
we'll have a we have a
you've got a promo code um
and a discount code i think i think so
what is it i should know that
yeah i don't know it's probably
baruch.com rich roll
i suspect but we'll put it in the show
notes yeah
yeah so you know and and we love your
customers because
they care they care about the
environment they care about their
nutrition
um and they care about the way we're
sustainably working with this this uh
important not only business model but
um this sacred nut that yeah
we've got to support it's cool yeah so
how's the podcast journey been for you
oh man
how many episodes have you done now uh i
think
i think by the by us talking here i
it's 13 or 14 yeah episodes
i've welcomed to the club thank you
yeah it was great timing i mean i have a
i mean for you to launch it essentially
just have like
how many episodes did you have out when
the show launched
i don't know maybe eight i mean
i know that it wasn't that timing wasn't
by design but it's
it it was brilliant yeah you did those
things together
yeah i was i was working on the podcast
for a while as you know
and uh you know just figuring it out i
had this
great company amplify out of australia
who's the engineers behind it so they
took off that burden and that labor and
so i just started getting used to just
interviewing people and doing that stuff
and so i've had a bunch in the can
and again you know the the tv show was
supposed to come out a year ago right
and so it was just by divine
plan that this all just lined up
together i launched the one two one
tribe app
which is a some recipes and functional
training
and information and water tracking
and the podcast that all just and then
then
then we got the i didn't know when
netflix
was gonna launch it we all didn't know
right and then all of a sudden the last
minute they gave us this date
and i'm like wow okay
so yeah people think that you have
control over those things no
no you had no idea which is why i just
like well okay so i'm potentially
developing another
tv show i'm staying focused on the
podcast
i'm gonna get that out i'm gonna stay
focused on this one two one tribe app
i'm just gonna keep creating because i
am dedicated to what i'm doing and then
i'm working on the sustainable stuff on
the side
not really on the side but on the
forefront but it takes a long time to
develop
some of these energy tech solutions with
these groups
and so i just creating and just happened
well it's a great
example of of luck and hard work
meets opportunity and luck right like
you just were plowing ahead
not waiting sitting around waiting for
the netflix show to come out like you
created all this other stuff
and divine timing kind of you know
coincided to have these things all
percolate
right around the same time and yeah sort
of feed each other
yeah that's amazing it's cool yeah but
the podcast
you seem like you're having fun with it
i love it yeah i i you know listen dude
i i mean
you know being here with you like just
us talking and
and getting into stuff about things we
care about
um i love it and i and and there's
voices that haven't been heard and
there's stories within every person
um using this microphone as a
conscious collaborator and and
you know ear to our conversation is
fantastic yeah and i love it and i'm
learning as you know
so much and exploring and my
entrepreneur entrepreneurial brain
and dna is just like oh my god let's
do more stuff with all of these great
people
so yeah i'm enjoying it a lot i think
what what you can bring to this that
that i haven't seen yet
is is shining a light on some of these
amazing people that you know because of
all the travels that you've gone on and
people that no one's ever heard of who
are who are like doing incredible things
super obscurely and you can be like tell
everyone about this
right you know yeah i mean if people
want to
check out like a perfect example of that
as uh episode number two
with my buddy chris patton you can't
even google search him
nothing will show up and this guy's been
dedicated to the planet and clean energy
tech
for 20 years and his life is centered
around the
civil unrest in western africa in the
90s when it blew up
and he was stabbed and he was shot and
has all he's lost all his friends and
and he survived it is this the blood
diamond guy this is the blood diamond
yeah so his
he sold his rights of
part of that journey into the what was
now the blood diamond movie with
leonardo dicaprio and yeah they took
some liberties and making it made it
into a blood diamond
situation but that wasn't what he was
doing but it was
that that he and then he spent the next
20 years dedicating his life to figuring
out
what what energy systems from
underground russian scientists to
obscure tesla technology and his own
science team
and working directly with nasa and
developing technology of
um of lunar habitat
uh power systems that from our point of
from from what we know now it's the only
power systems that
they've signed off on so this guy
and i've known him for 17 years and we
resonate
in this way of commitment i think
he's utterly committed to
not having this planet fall apart in our
hands
to create um better uses
of non-nuclear
no emissions no waste power systems and
he's done it
and i can't wait to scream from the
highest mountaintops
on what he's doing and what we're
involved with
yeah more guys like that right yeah cool
well i can't let you go without leaving
leaving people with a couple things that
they can
take with them the show did such a great
job of of talking about
a lot of the stuff that you care about
in a very macro sense like we go to
iceland and we see how they're
generating
sustainable power but it's like all
right well what can i do you know what
what am i
how do i translate that into something
actionable in my day-to-day life so
i think you know it would be great
through the lens of
sustainability and personal health to
leave people with a couple
simple practices that they could think
about and perhaps
integrate into their lives that would
help them
well i think that's more clear thank you
and i think more
clear than ever people need to be
healthy they need to
stop distracting themselves and eat more
plants
and figure out a program that's going to
work and get healthy
because we need strong people
to do that give me a little vegan bicep
flex right now
there you go come on
dude so so so we need
strong healthy happy people
non-judgmentally
kicking ass in their life and i really
believe that's the
purpose of health so that you can kick
ass in your life and have the fulfilling
life you want so you're not miserable
with a chemistry set that isn't working
so find a different way if it's
you know your app if it's my app the one
two one tribe if it's
finding a group of people even online or
whatever that you can
move and explore and just you know
find recipes that work eat better uh
hydrate yourself
without a doubt that's the that's the
easiest one i think environmentally
and it may feel like people have heard
this before but single-use plastic
my god we need to stop quit buying
you know cartons and containers and
water bottles that you're
literally just using and throwing away
unless you have a technology that you're
able to
use paralysis and break down the plastic
and turning into fuel for your tesla
which actually exists so i
so i'm mentioning it for a reason unless
you have that technology
stop using the the single-use plastic do
everything you can
and and this goes hand in hand to that
is
start being aware of the unsustainable
business practices
of companies and big companies and
support and maybe pay a little extra
money for your food
for your conveniences to support
companies that are doing things right
supporting companies that are being
transparent with what they're doing and
what they're offering
and that is absolutely something you can
do right now
and demand that support those small
of course right now support the small
businesses right now
and if anything i know so many more
from all of them reaching out from the
show that there are some great
people doing incredible things that
people don't know about
so look at your dental floss that
glide dental floss that is creating
putting
toxins in your liver by this chemicals
of
pgas and all of this other stop using
that company because that company
doesn't give a [ __ ] about you
use a bamboo string or whatever like
that's literally
what i'm saying stop the toxic exposure
to yourself and your life
and support companies that are actually
giving a [ __ ] about you i think those
are
a lot of things that we can do um to
put attention on what needs attention
and stop putting your hard-earned money
and attention on companies that don't
care and have never cared
people are busy they don't want to or
they don't have the bandwidth to
devote the energy and time to trying to
figure out who's doing things right and
who
isn't are there any resources that you
rely on to
figure that out yeah it's a great
question actually i'm trying to mobilize
and use
a sub part of the app as that
kind of a wellness warrior ambassador
program i don't know the name
yet but we have started an outline
to to create attention towards brands
that are doing things right
create current events that are uh and
charities and organizations that are
doing things right so
so i'm just now starting that i'm
starting that with
you know the generation z kids so
so that they can
mobilize themselves in that direction
but but no
i don't i don't know and um this is
something that we all need to know a
little bit more about
not being preached to but replacing
those things that we're doing on a daily
basis because we're
we're using single-use plastic way too
much
and we can stop that and we're also
just not aware of
[Music]
you know that's why i do a segment on
the on the podcast called fatal
conveniences where i reveal
some of these things that you don't even
realize you're doing
to then have this chemical that you're
being exposed to but then have a
solution for it so
we do need to move in that direction and
all the listeners please reach out to me
and reach out to rich and give us
suggestions because i definitely
want to support that movement yeah i
watched
uh this movie the other night called an
american pickle with
seth rogen premiered on hbo and the
young
seth rogen plays two characters he plays
his great grandfather and he
and great grandson at the same time and
the great grandson
is like this kid living in williamsburg
brooklyn he's an app developer and he's
working on this app
that he came up with that is that very
thing
where you hold your phone up the camera
on your phone and you hold it up to a
product
and then it it it runs it through some
calculus and database and comes up with
a score and gives you its environmental
footprint and impact and ingredients and
toxins and all of that and i was like
we should have that that should be a
thing that exists in the world
absolutely you know let's do it maybe
there's some version of that out there
if somebody knows let me know because i
would like to know let's see
maybe you should build that darren maybe
we should build it maybe we should call
seth rogen
see how he did it okay well seth rogen i
know i can get to him yeah
okay um good man i love you brother
thank you so much for doing this i'm so
proud of you
your success is so overdue and
well earned i mean what what year did
super life come out like four or five
years ago
yeah the end of 15. have there been how
many other books came out
and then made the new york times
bestseller list like five years later i
don't know
i mean you know that's a funny thing so
cool
because and thank you and you know i
think you remember i chose to just take
an organic route
with the book just like just let it out
and
let it have its own i didn't want to you
know
there's a weird it happened because it
was supposed to happen not because you
forced it yeah you know and there's a
beautiful lesson in that i think
yeah yeah man but i i
thank you and this full circle of
the show kind of being birthed
by our conversation here
because if zach heard something that you
allowed me to share from and the space
that you provide
i see the your opening
and your ability to constantly have
incredible conversations with people and
i'm proud of you
because i know also that you've
stretched yourself
to have the success and had
vulnerability
in order to to to expand
to this level i remember those
conversations and i'm equally proud of
you
yeah thanks brother um it's been a
journey
yeah proud to take it and blaze it with
you yeah man
so you're welcome here anytime uh
proud to be your friend and keep rocking
it man
i plan on it so if you want to connect
with darren at darynoleen
on his instagram it's blowing up like
crazy uh the book is super life
baruch.com some kind of promo code maybe
i'll let you guys know and uh what else
man the one two one tribe app
yeah pretty cool one two one tribe.com
yep people can go there there's three
free days you can get some
movement plants some breathing stuff and
you can check it out
you can buy it if you want but right
that's three it's free
and down to earth on netflix down door
and i i was gonna ask you what do you
have coming
up but that's like another three hour
podcast yep
so just an excuse to have you come back
100 all right
peace brother love you peace
[Music]
you